- [Voiceover] I wanna
talk a little bit about
one of the quirkier ideas
in signal processing,
and that's the idea of negative frequency.
This is a phrase that initially
may not make any sense
at all, what does it mean
to be a negative frequency?
Could there be a sine
wave that goes up and down
at a rate of minus 10 cycles per second,
what on earth does that mean?
Or could there be a radio
station of minus 680 kilohertz?
What is that, that doesn't
sound like it means anything.
There is a sense in
which negative frequency
is understandable and
we're gonna just quickly
talk about that here.
You remember, we can
describe a cosine like this,
cosine of omega t equals
1/2 e to the plus j omega t,
plus e to the minus j omega t.
And each of these components,
each of these complex exponentials here,
we can draw as a rotating complex number.
So for this first one, we
could actually draw it,
if we wanted to, we
could draw it like this,
we could draw a complex
number out here in space,
and think of it as a rotating vector,
and that would be e to the j omega t.
This one has a plus sign.
Now the other thing, this term over here,
would look like a similar thing,
it would be sum vector and space,
there's that number right
there, e to the minus j omega t,
and this one's rotating
in the negative direction.
So that means this is rotating this way.
So the idea of a negative frequency,
when we talk about rotating
vectors, makes good sense.
If we are rotating in the
positive direction, like this,
you could say that's a positive frequency.
And if we're rotating in the
negative direction, like this,
you could say that's a negative frequency.
So omega t gives us the speed,
and this sign right here,
give us the direction.
The frequency here is plus omega t,
and the frequency here is minus omega t.
So in this sense of rotating vectors,
negative frequency seems
like a pretty simple idea.
Okay, so let's go where
it's not a simple idea,
and that's when we do
this thing we did before
where we projected these
vectors onto a cosine wave,
it had spread out the time
axis linearly, like this,
going down the page for
the cosine, remember,
we did this, we drew a
line here on this side,
we're gonna do plus omega t.
So we're gonna plot e to
the plus j omega t here.
This will be the real axis,
this will be the imaginary axis,
and down here, this'll
be the voltage axis,
and this'll be the time axis.
So when we start out at
time equals zero, we have,
we project it down here, and
we got that value right there.
And then as time goes on,
if we tip our arrow up,
like that, to that point,
then we project down to the
cosine curve right here.
If we let our arrow go all
the way to the other side,
it projects like this down,
it projects down to this
point on the cosine curve.
And as we go farther and farther,
let's go straight down for a second,
that one projects to right there.
and as we come over here,
it projects to that point right there.
And eventually, when we
get back to home again,
when we get back to zero,
the projection is right
to this point here.
And so with one rotation
we've carved out one cycle
of the cosine.
So that seems pretty clear.
Omega t is there, omega t is down here.
Okay, so let's do it again,
but this time we'll go over on this side,
and we'll plot e to the minus j omega t.
So this again is the real axis,
and this is the imaginary.
And this is the voltage axis,
and this is the time axis.
So let's start out again,
we're going straight sideways
to time equals zero, so
let's project that down.
And okay, that's pretty good,
that's the same as before,
we got the same v here.
Now let's tip it down,
let's say we rotate this way a little bit,
and here's our new position of our vector.
And that projection, after
a little bit of time,
goes to right here.
And then if we go over this way,
eventually, rotate some more,
we'll project to this point here.
And when we're straight sideways,
it'll project to this peak right here.
And you can see what's
happening is basically
the exact same thing is happening
as happened on the left.
Which is these points
carve out a cosine wave,
just as we'd expect,
and when this vector gets all
the way back around to zero,
we've done one cycle, we're back home,
and now we're projecting
to this point here.
What happened here is we
took two different vectors
rotating in opposite directions,
this one clearly had a positive frequency
cause it was going counter-clockwise.
This one had a negative frequency
cause it was going clockwise.
And both of them carved out
the exact same cosine wave,
when we got done.
So in the vector world where
we're spinning vectors around,
it seems very natural to talk
about plus and minus frequency
but when we cast this back
into say a real-world v of t,
notice that the idea of
negative frequency just sort of,
it melts away, it evaporates,
it's not really there anymore.
And it's been removed by
this process of projection.
So when the idea of
negative frequency comes up,
and it seems like it
doesn't make sense in this
time to main view of the signals,
but then just remember that
when we go back up here,
and we look at the rotating vectors,
that it just means which
way the vector's spinning.